Herkese
merhabalar Benim de bir hayalim de bu
Gerçekten hepimiz birilerinin
hayallerinizi
gerçekleştiriyoruz Belki bugün de
anlatacağım öyle bir hikaye bir kadının
hikayesi Ama önce Diyorum ki bana burada
büyüsün Hakkı verdiler ya sus durabilene
Aşk olsun Çünkü kadın susla susmuşsa
gitmiş demektir Ama bu başka bir hikaye
şu an Yeri burası değil kadın susmaz ve
kadını sığdıramaz Aslında 10 dakikaya 15
dakikaya Ben Bilirim ki burada 10
dakikaya 15 dakikaya sığdıramam gerekir
Ama Kadın İsterse
sığdırır Çünkü kadın bir süre eşyayı
küçücük bir odaya sığdırır bir minicik
kavanozlara rengarenk reçelleri saldırır
bir su bardağına Denizi sığdır kadına
bol bol çantasına eczaneyi sığdırır
makyaj malzemelerini sığdırır
ruhuna geceyi sığdırır kadın bir
elbiseye anılarını sığdırır bir şarkıya
kış kırıklarını
bir bakışa şehveti sığdırır kadın bir
dokunuş abla şevketi
yürüyüşe umursamazlığı sığdırır kadın
bir dudak bir kışıda yanılmazlığı
sığdırır bir gülüşe
unutulmayı sığdırır kadın ve içtiği
sigaraya efkârı nın Bir Fincan Kahve ye
ye
anılarını
sırlarını sığdırır kadın
bir suça çığlıklarını sığdırır bir kadın
bir erkeği bir ömür Kalbine sığdırır bir
bebeği karnına ve bir çocuğu hayatı
nasıl atılır bir ömür bir her şeyi
sığdırır da kadın bir kendi sığmaz
kendini sığdıramaz Şu koskoca dünyaya
[Alkış]
Ya aslında bugün burada bu konuşmayı
dinliyor Sak şu anda Bu salonda yasak Bu
kadının sonsuzluğun dan gelen bir
hikayedir Bir taraftan baktığınızda
Beni doğuran bu kadın gibi Onu da
doğuran diğer kadınlar gibi Çünkü kadın
üreten dir kadın doğurgandır toplumun
yargılarına karşı kadın vazgeçmeyen
kadın ayakta duran Iğdır kadın yeniden
yeniden kendini doğurgandır bir hava ile
Adem'den bu yana Bugün bir kadın
anlatmaya geldim size
toplumu yargılarına karşı duran bir
kadını bir köy yerinde den öğretmen
adayı bir yakışıklı genç ile karşılaşan
bir kadını heyoka demrehava değil onlar
nimet ile Mustafa'nın hikayesi Mustafa
köyün yakışıklısı
sıkı hizmet köy köy enstitülerinde öğren
o
öretmen olacak altı çocuklu ailenin en
büyüğü ahali ondan okul bekler ver
meslek bekler kendilerini o köyden
çıkarmalarını bekler Yazgı çizgisi
çizilmiş çoktan ama Nimet köy kızı
simsiyah saçları keskin bakışlarıyla
birlikte altı kardeşin en büyüğü okula
bile Gönderilmemiş okuma yazması olmayan
bir kadın kendisi
Çöllerinde karşılaşırlar Mustafa'yla ile
Mustafa Mağrur karşısında durur nimet-i
Nereye gidiyorsun ders
Bu tarlaya diye Söyler Nimet
elindekine
eline bakar Nimet
yoğurt çengili ile sofra bezine sarılı
ekmekleri gösterir Yoğurtlu ekmek
anamgil lrp tarlaya götürüyor işçilere
bu Mustafa durur onu bana verir misin
veririm Tabii der gülümseyerek al al
olmuş yanaklarıyla ve o gün yoğurt ve
ekmeği Mustafa sınav erir Aslında
verdiği kalbi ve ruhunu temsil en de
tahmin edersiniz ki o öğlen Nimet varır
tarlaya ne de Yoğurtlu ekmek
gerisini siz düşünün
artıkk yaz biter sonbahar şehre dönüş
vakti kadın Arafta kardeşlerine bakın
verir şehirde yazları da tarlada
annesine
annesi duygularıyla birlikte
bu nimetin babasını da toprağa vermiş
kadınlığını da beraber
kaskatı beklediği sadece kardeşlerine
bakın vermekte kendi doğurmamış Sada
diğer kardeşlerine küçücük annelik eder
onlara ondan beklenen şekilde
bu
mevsimler döner bir sonraki
yıldı zaman yeniden Mustafa'yı köye
getirir
yemedi de tekrar tarlaya yardıma
bulunduğu yer
eeee Metin yoğurt ve ekmek verdiği yerde
yeniden karşılaşırlar bu sefer Mustafa
durur karşısında ne der ki
Ben sana aşık oldum Bana varır mısın
Nimet yoğurtlu ekmeği verdiği gibi
kalbini verdiği gibi kabul eder evlenme
teklifini varırım ya
ders Fakat
bu Mustafa'nın annesi Raziye hatun
ne ister mi ki okumamış geline kör cahil
okuma yazması olmayan bir köy kazanı
benim oğlum ona kalmamış diye haber
salar nimetin annesine nimetin annesi
gururlu Mağrur Benim de ortada kalmış
kızım yok der anneler telaşta birisi
makam derdim değil
var ama çocuklar Sevda da da neyse ki
Mustafa kararlı
henüz ayrılmadan önce nişan temsili
yüzüğü parmağına takan ya Metin Tamam
maalesef mevsim tekrar döndüğünde
körpecik İnşallah ısısını orada bırakıp
geri dönmek zorunda kalır Aksu
öğretmenevinde
okulun ardından pılısını pırtısını
toplayan Raziye Hatun koşar gider oğluna
ikna eder Ve orada başka birisini
nişanlar
öğretmen olacak yeni gelini i
parmağındaki nişan temsili yüzüğü
gururla çantasında taşıyarak köye geri
getirir benim oğlum sana kalmamış
Derneğimize Nimet üzülür ezilir kör
cahil bir kız olduğu yüzüne vurulur
okumamış lıı okutulma mı şlı ğı yüzün
Sen
gel zaman git zaman köy enstitülerinde
okurken top koştur Mustafa o zamanlar
Adana Demirspor'un en ünlü
oyuncularından biri boy boy gazetelerde
yazar Nimet bir gün gazeteyi açar ki
Mustafa hikaye bu ya ayağını kırmış
çıktığı bir maçta Doktorlar kötürüm
kalır artık yürüyemez demişler
ver Raziye Hatun Bunu duyunca hemen
yemedi haber salar Çünkü yeni nişanlısı
Mustafa'yı terk eder Öyle ya tekerlekli
sandalyede biriyle bir ömür geçiremez
ama Nimet koşar gider yanına
ayaklarına değil Sana Vurgunum Ben
seninleyim sonsuza kadar der
Evren aşklarını Duyar hisseder
Mustafa'nın ayağa iyileşir okulunu
bitirip öğretmen olamasa da Bu bir yere
memur atanır
en gözde Postanesi
bir göz evlerinde ne yatak ne organ var
yatmak için ne tava ne tencere bu
komşular yardım eder bu yeni evli çifte
ve fakat öyleki
iki kadının çocuğu olmuyor
bu ahali çocuk bekler
Raziye Hatun çocuk bekler her
etrafındaki herkes Çocuk bekler de
kadının çocuğu olmuyor
kadının çocuğu olmuyor rafları Dolanır
civarda ve söylentilerle
kadın genç Mustafa'ya Bir Çocuk dahi
veremiyor
bu daha çok ezilir daha çok üzülür cahil
satılan cahil görülen Nimet et bir kızı
olsun ister Oysa
gelecek kadınlara Işık olacak
okuyacak okutacak temsil olacak güç
olacak bir kızı ister kız olsun
isterse tam vazgeçmek üzereyken
Herşeyden
öğrenirler ki iki kadın gebe
yaşanmamış hayallerine gibi
bilinmemiş kadınlığına GB
sen her şeye gebe ve bir oğlu olur
kızını isterken ben masmavi gözleri
sapsarı saçlarıyla bebek çok yaşamaz
maalesef 35 ay sonra yumar gözlerini bu
sefer yine suçlanır kadın bir çocuğa
bile bakamadı
o Raziye Hatun çocuk bekler
Mahalle çocuk bekler Mustafa çocuk
bekler kadın artık hiçbir şey beklemez
susar hayata güzel
Evet tamam tamam vazgeçecek Ken
Herşeyden yine öğrenir ki gibi artık
umudu da kalmamıştır son nefesini kızını
doldurabilmek için verir o sırada hebe
seslenir kız
bir kızınız oldu kadın gözlerini açar
gözyaşlarıyla dolu gözlerinden sicim
gibi akar
şükreder minnet eder Berk adına gün
hayallerini gerçekleştirir
kadın o gün çocukluk hayallerine
kadınlık hayallerine gençlik hayallerini
gerçekleştirir o küçücük bebeğe kendi
hayallerini yükler o bebeğe O Zaman bu
zamandır bir bilgi olma yolunda devam
eder ve
Az
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
önce okur
burs sonra okutur
ve döner annesine der ki
kadının çocuğu oluyor your
[Alkış]
bu
hayata gözlerini yummuş
nimetini de kızına emanet vermiş
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
He iş